für mein türkei urlaub habe ich
eigentlich mit seiner offenen nicht
lachen challenge vorproduziert vor
anderthalb wochen da ich das allerdings
in der türkei nicht geschafft habt
zuschneiden lade ich euch das jetzt so
viel spaß
dann sehe ich wirklich zwingend dass die
inhaltliche zu hören aber ich war sie
mit sicherheit ihr zwingen dass sie
nicht irgendwie stöpsel oder und das
überhaupt nicht mehr mit ihnen reden
kann auch sollen das intensive leben
nehmen wir müssen uns heute mal richtige
challenge ansehen und dass das war halt
ein uhr nachts und unser taxi zum
flughafen ging um 34 von daher war mir
ziemlich am arsch in diesem video schaut
einfach weiter ganz im ernst ich hatte
er auf ein kleines geschenk gehabt
ich habe ja schon das leben geschenkt
also über teils nicht schon wieder
verpackt mir glaub ich anders es macht
ja keinen sinn etwas lustiges sich
anzugucken
obwohl man nicht lachen darauf ist ja
genauso wenn du dir vor du bestellst du
was leckeres essen das leckere essen
aber nicht essen das ist ja die
challenge
ja
er war mal bei mir im zimmer für das ist
wirklich im supermarkt ja klar wie der
markt das ist noch mal was gesagt also
wenn der dunst in die wohnung zieht dann
gar noch 3 tage das haus betreten
[Musik]
wann ist der song ich sechs war noch
nicht wie das plötzlich zustande kamen
apa sozialen männer heute aufgewacht
egal wie egal was hauptsache asozial ja
also richtig mit button deutschen reiter
der sich mein sohn ich bin schwul ist
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
seit wann ist jetzt angemeldet ich hab
immer lich meinem betrieb gerade
abgeholt
das sieht man die karte da abgeholt da
ich demnächst mal wenn ich ihr dann
meinst also ich finde gar nicht das
schnurren ist als einfach geben nehmen
[Gelächter]
das ist auch richtig deutsch presseraum
die sonne karte von tiergarten
würde käme das du nie wieder ab los die
sie nie wieder haben du hast doch was
ist das ich weiß auch nicht solche
videos war das sollte jetzt auch wir
kommen ja noch die idee sich zu denken
heute stelle ich nicht meinen sportacus
von lazytown kostüme nämlich auf ist
einmal wild es ist einfach wild sondern
es heißt immer noch wild wild warum bist
du so bodenständig wenn ich laufe auch
den bodenständig
[Musik]
stifter ehrlich auf den boden der job
hat halt leider von mir kommen können
also ich finde den humor und witzig und
findet das witzig weil lukas seit
ungefähr einwohner komische kreation
seinem körper hier selber bildet da ich
sagte djv-sprecher hier schon mal
jemandem korb gegeben
ja
[Applaus]
lukas hat er ordentlich rein gelochten
aus sechs schulen
man überlegt was ich so kombinieren so
dass die musik noch die knochen das ist
so komisch der einstellung oder kennst
du wenn du richtig lang kacken war es
nun danach steht zu kaufen und dann beim
schlafen so lueg ag der
dreiviertelstunde kacken
ja ich will boxen ich höre wenn das
einer meiner schwester navy werden jetzt
aber da wo du willst ja nicht mehr so
weit kommen lassen wir das thema mit
dummheit erstmal an der stelle würden
wir heute nicht lachen challenge ist
allerdings auch beenden meine lieben
freunde wenn es euch gefallen hat alles
gern einen daumen hoch unter dem video
history dass das heutige video ein
bisschen kürzer war allerdings es ist
gerade 81 müssen in drei stunden auch ja
was sie erwischen und zum flughafen
fahren weil in die türkei fliegen
das was ihr ziel kombi oder das was
jetzt hier vom video hier können jetzt
hier meinen kanal abonnieren oder hier
unten mal einen job aus checken jetzt
findet ihr zwei andere videos und
belgischen abonnenten zeit könnt ihr
auch die glocke klicken dann willkommen
die benachrichtigungen
[Musik]